next monday our two biggest major sports
teams they're gonna collide on the
diamond it's the annual battle for vegas
the golden knights las vegas raiders on
the softball field all for a great cause
joining us this morning to talk about it
james sullivan co-founder not only of
the game itself but also las vegas
agency and tammy hans lair with the
communities and schools of nevada ceo we
thank you both for coming in this
morning thank you this is a big deal of
course it's such a great crowd out at
las vegas ballpark james let's just talk
to folks maybe who aren't familiar with
the game what it is and who it benefits
so it's a charity softball game that was
founded by riley smith of golden knights
we're in our third year um each year it
hits riley and his teammates against a
teammate up of the raiders so this
year's captain will be josh jacobs
and like i say it's a it's a great uh
family fun event at las vegas ballpark
uh would be monday night and and tammy
it's all for charity and every every
year these three years it's all
benefiting local organizations talk
about how this will help
people here in the valley it's not just
a good time to watch some softball but
the money's going to a great place well
i mean and you know las vegas is so
community focused we couldn't be prouder
to be part of this of this game this
year so thank you very much to everybody
who's putting it together
communities and schools is a dropout
prevention organization and we work in
our title one schools right here in
clark county
this year we'll be in 65 title 1 schools
across the valley and all money that's
raised here will stay right here love to
see that james where else is the benefit
of the the money going for the game out
in the community uh well the other
cherry so we each year we pick two
charities uh community schools is one
the other one is a charity called
maximum hope which is the foundation
founded by brad garrett
and that goes to families with children
that are dealing with uh
life-threatening illnesses excellent
causes so folks want to go tickets still
available tickets are still available
you can get tickets either on our
website battlefrontvegas.com you can get
the las vegas ballpark or at
ticketmaster.com and you were hinting at
this there's a special surprise guest
that's been announced who who's going to
be taking part in the game yes we just
confirmed marshawn lynch marshawn lynch
beast mode skill time
so he's playing huh he is playing he
will be there he is playing i don't know
how good he is we haven't seen him play
yet but we'll we'll find out monday
night you know it's interesting though
we've seen over the years the surprising
talents at the softball dish for the
raiders and for the golden knights we
saw nate schmidt's amazing catch last
year riva all these guys are are great
on the diamond it's very such a great
cause yeah it's like i say it's a fun
night uh you get to see the players
outside of their their element and then
we end the night with fireworks so like
i said it's a great family fun event
well james and tammy thank you very much
for coming in this morning it's such a
fun event here in the valley to have
once again it is on monday night las
vegas ballpark tickets are still
available check it out battle for vegas
guys thanks for coming in this morning
appreciate it thank you